the world is coming undone Imperial  flags rain across the galaxy  we have intercepted a coded Imperial  transmission it indicates that a major  weapons test is imminent  the message was sent by your father we  need to know what it is and how to  destroy it this is our chance to make a  real difference if you're really doing  this I want to help  good I've been recording for the  rebellion for all time would you join  our Oh my side the entire night I fear  nothing  all is as the Force Wilson every day  they grow stronger what will you do  when they catch you  you do a creaky  if you continue to fight  what will you  are you with me all the way  may the force be with us  trust it without your shackles let's  just get this over with shall we  we've a mission for you  a major weapons test is in